the john harvey arms is at the center of
the community
and they were looking forward to
swinging open their doors at the end of
lockdown
but this part is just inside tier three
in bristol and will have to remain
closed
even though the next nearest pub just a
few hundred meters away
in tier two can start serving drinks
so as you can see we're in the middle of
putting all our christmas decorations up
don't know why we bothered now to get
tier three today i mean we were
expecting it but still it's
a massive blow they're not going to
review until december the 16th
i'm absolutely furious about it because
you know if you're going to do that on
an area it should be every pub
or restaurant in that area not by
borderlines or council lines
it's not fair around the edges of the
tears
it does feel to many like a postcode
lottery as to where your house ends up
when it comes to the geography of covid
restrictions
the difference between tier three and
tier two on the ground
doesn't feel like anything at all tier
three over here is bristol
and in the middle of this road you have
tier two the boundary
with bath and northeast somerset but
that fine line
makes a massive difference to how you
live your life and that is why for many
people
it is so frustrating in no west
back inside tier three in bristol
infection rates
are relatively low for the city but the
draconian measures remain in place
for everyone yeah it's hard especially
with christmas coming up
with like kids having birthdays in that
not being able to see like family i'm a
bit disappointed because
i usually because for my mug got my
daughter down
in her car i used to go down and see her
quite often
yeah it definitely is a diner yeah um
with everything that's been going on
especially
it's for everybody just a few miles away
into what will be tier two in keynesian
they're not putting up christmas
decorations with much enthusiasm
either jim mccarthy's pub doesn't serve
food so he'll remain closed losing money
at what should be the busiest time of
the year you can go get your nails done
with a
person stood right next to her in front
of you hair done etc
but you cannot come and sit in a pub and
have a beer
tier three or tier two for many people
it is just degrees of unhappiness the
festive season may be upon us
but for most of the country with tough
restrictions in place until who knows
when
there's not much to cheer about alex
rossi
sky news bristol